hello I'm Amara shrek and i'm the CEO of
Medtronic a medical devices company
mobile devices complete I've just come
from a session on the technology context
and that was a finalist not session and
I found it to be very useful and
stimulating in many ways we talked a lot
about a culture of innovation and
companies whether we can innovate big
companies or small companies and what
kinds of people are required to drive
that level of innovation and we heard
from a variety of panelists and it was
indeed very stimulating the answer in
the end in many ways was that leadership
is what counts it can be in big
companies or in small companies a
culture of innovation is important
risk-taking is important and we also
briefly touched on different types of
technologies very useful and thing that
stood out for me was the ability to use
software and analytics to provide
intelligent decision support is
something they'll be very destructive
going forward so rich session and I
enjoyed a lot I Follett River